Ouais, fait que
je vais me mettre à YouTube.
J'ai euh
j'ai écouté des vidéos qui parlaient de
euh
qu'il fallait que tu crées de la valeur.
Le le volume, la grandeur de
du résultat que tu vas avoir, c'est
ce que tu as créé.
Puis je me rendais compte que moi,
j'étais beaucoup dans l'optimisation
de toutes les choses que je fais dans ma
vie. optimiser pour être efficace,
optimiser pour faire plus mais sans
nécessairement focus sur
apporter de la valeur aux gens.
Donc c'est pour ça que je vais me mettre
à YouTube
puis je veux créer un maximum de vidéos
sans montage.
En tout cas, pour commencer montage, je
veux réduire au maximum les
les barrières
les barrières à l'entrée, tout ce qui
peut
écurer un peu, on pourrait dire.
Je veux rendre ça le plus easy going
possible.
Donc euh
ouais, c'est ça
parce qu'à l' en ce moment,
on est beaucoup axé sur euh
je sais pas, il faudrait que je fasse
des vidéos mais je sais pas, je script
dessus, je pense je pas le choix de de
faire des scripts, sinon tu vas perdre
ton temps à chaque fois.
C'est ça faut que tuécrives.
Tu un plan de ce que tu veux dire un
brainstorm.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que j'ai à dire ? Je sais même
pas je vais parler de quoi dans ces
vidéos là
parce que ce que je me suis rendu compte
c'est que tu peux pas te baser sur ce
que L va te donner.
Bit
pas un bon contexte que tu donnes à
tu vas pas
ah tu vas avoir des des idées de vidéos
qui vont être basic que tout le monde va
déjà fait 10000 fois puis ça va donner
quoi qui est
qui est pas pertinent au final
j'ai juste le goût juste de faire des
vidéos
puis de pas me concer à tête avec ce que
je vais dire dedans juste parler mes
expériences de ce que j'ai ce que je vis
en ce moment
puis ce que j'en apprends
puis que ça peut apporter aux autres.
Au final, je pense que je vais juste
faire des vidéos
en me mettant dans la peau de moi
avant
genre de moi il y a peut-être 2 3 ans
qui savait pas pas ce qu'il voulait
faire en vie
puis qui était perdu un peu un peu
beaucoup. Je suis encore perdu
d'ailleurs en ce moment
mais
qui a avancé qui essayé des choses faire
des vidéos dans le mindset de
qu'est-ce que moi dans le temps j'aurais
aimé ça
faire des rappels
ce que j'ai vécu dans le
dans le pass expériences
Puis on va voir où c'est que ça va où
c'est que ça va me mener.
Fait que je voulais aborder une chose,
c'était le fait que
tu auras pas le choix si tu vas avoir
des résultats grands, tu auras pas le
choix pendant
longtemps de faire de c tu es pas bon.
Puis tu es pas à l'aise de faire, tu
auras pas le choix de le faire pendant
longtemps avant de recevoir du résultat.
C'est hyper simple comme
concept,
mais en direct dans la société
d'aujourd'hui, on n'est pas
euh on se pousse pas à aller dans cette
inconfort là de essayer des choses, mais
pas juste les essayer, c'est des faire
puis de d'y aller dedans à fond
puis que même si tu es pas bon, tu
continues. continu tu continues, tu
continues, tu apprends, tu apprends, tu
lis, tu demandes des conseils puis tu
continues.
Puis
ben comme ça tu vas un mé devenir
pas pire un mé tu v devenir correcté tu
vas devenir
bon
puis continue devenir excellent tu vas
devenir un maître dans ce que tu fais
dans la chose que tu étais pas du tout
bon avant moi j'ai travaillé dans les
bords
pendant plusieurs années
Pendant plusieurs années, j'ai travaillé
dans les bars comme barman.
Puis au début, je trouvais ça vraiment
difficile de euh
de te coucher tard first de parler à
plein de gens que tu t'en fous là
de de de d'être sur la pression. Veux
pas, tu as quand même tu sais tuas de la
musique, tuas du monde qui crie après
qui te demande "Eh, viens pas ici, je
veux me commander tout.
pendant ce temps-là de devoir créer une
relation avec quelqu'un, de parler puis
tout, t'intéresser à eux
pour créer un bon feeling avec la
personne, une certaine confiance avec le
client.
Puis au début cit vraiment vraiment
difficile même au point que je me disais
que je vais je vais faire un été là
l'été c'est fini je vais l'avoir essayé
puis ça va être ça va être terminé pour
moi.
Finalement, j'ai fait un été,
j'ai eu une autre opportunité qui est
arrivée
puis directement quand elle était
terminée, j'ai quitter mon emploi de
dans un bar rentrer dans un autre bar.
J'ai d je l'essay
puis finalement je suis resté 2 ou 3 ans
encore à ce job là
parce que j'étais rendu bon. J'avais
passé 3 mois 4 mois à faire de quoi que
j'étais pas le meilleur, j'étais pas
tant bon que ça finalement d'apprendre
d'apprendre d'apprendre puis de devenir
à l'aise dans ce que tu fais devenir
efficace
mais c'est tu peux pas te rendre là
si tu as pas passé par toutes les étapes
d'avant de je suis pas bon je suis pas
bon puis c'est pas naturel c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas
j'ai l'impression que je ti bas les
autres autour de moi. C'est un peu ça
que je veux faire avec les vidéos, c'est
de commencer dans ce processus là de je
commence de quoi que je ne suis pas bon,
que j'ai pas d'expérience
puis de le faire tellement longtemps que
mé tu deviens pas pire
pour devenir bon.
Donc c'est ça le processus que je veux
enter aujourd'hui,
le fait de commencer quelque chose, de
savoir
que je suis pas bon, que j'ai fait des
moments aussi que je parle puis que
c'est long, peut-être que je réfléchis
puis que
ça demanderait de montage mais je je va
pas en faire au début parce que
j'ai pas le goût d'en faire, j'ai pas le
goût de me ralentir avant de faire des
vidéos à cause que ah c'est du montage
puis tout. Je veux que ce soit le plus
lean possible comme process, le plus
relaxe, mais relaxe en mode
euh
exigence
mais
focus puis constant
dans l'énergie que je vais y mettre
toujours de toujours vouloir m'améliorer
puis de comprendre le processus, comment
ça fonctionne.
Donc c'est ça le l'objectif. derrière
cette chaîne YouTube.
Donc euh écoutez, je sais qu'il y aura
pas personne dans cette vidéolà. Je vais
être seul avec ma vidéo
mais
que je veux to un p qui est constant
plusieurs mois, plusieurs années
jusqu'àattends de devenir bon dans ce
que je fais parce que j'ai le goût de de
découvrir cette
ce monde là, la création de contenu
parce qu'on vit dans un monde je me perd
dans mes idées mais on vit dans un monde
où c'est que de plus en plus avec L puis
tout on devient tout sur nos écrans tout
le temps sur nos écrans à
pas créer de liens humains et tout
puis je trouve qu'il est plus important
que jamais d'apporter de la valeur aux
gens
d'une manière différente que par
le filtre de parce que pas on fait on
crée
avec l'outil qu'il y a puis que ça donne
un hardc
mais au final on fait jamais de quoi qui
est par nous-même c'est tout le temps
de l outc
je sais pas jeener avec ça mais juste de
faire des choses que c'est moi qui crée
qui donne c'est ça
d'avoir des relations humaines relié à
Ça,
je sais pas si c'est clair. Écoutez,
c'est un peu euh c'est brouillon ma
vidéo. C'est vraiment brouillon.
Mais euh
j'ai le goût de la l'envoyer comme ça
vidéo. Ça fait 11 minutes 27. Il y a eu
des moments de silence dedans à plus
finir.
Puis je sais sans doute que je vais
regarder ces vidélà plus tard puis je
vais faire bo
manqué d'amour cette vidéolà mais euh
je me dis que il faut que je me lance
faut que je fasse de quoi. Premment
aussi qu' a de l'éco aussi dans pièce
parce que je suis
dans une chambre
qui qui fait full écho mais c'est la ch
chambre qui comme il y avait un beau
background puis que c'était clean avec
des petites des petites plantes. Je me
suis dit que ça va être làdedans. Puis
mon objectif avec euh cette chaîne
YouTube, c'est euh d'être moi-même.
Je veux
je vois plein de monde qui font des
vidéos YouTube puis qui essayent de
faire de quoi qui euh
qui est comme qui fit avec le moule,
mant qui fit avec
ce qu'on voit sur YouTube en ce moment.
Mais
j'ai mon objectif c'est d'être moimême
dans mes vidéos.
d'être le plus moi-même possible puis
d'apprendre à me connaître aussi
à propos d'être seul.
Ouais,
fait que c'est ça, c'est ma première
vidéo YouTube.
Donc écoutez, même pas le montage. J'éte
j'éte mon ma caméra avec mes doigts
comme ça. Donc
écoutez, c'était la première. On est
le 25
avril 2026. Donc
c'était ma première vidéo.